[Music]
It's pig heart week on the king of random
Hey what up guys in this video we're carrying on with the heart theme
Now in a previous video I took a pig heart
cast it in silicon and turned it into an edible chocolate heart for valentine's day
And I was going to take the original pig heart that came out of the silicon mold
and freeze it in liquid nitrogen, so we could chip away at it.
but a lot of you in the comments have been asking to put the pig heart in a vacuum chamber first.
So for this video we're going to try just that.
We're going to answer what does a heart do in a vacuum chamber.
See from this direction it actually does look a little more like a heart.
Like you get the actual heart shape there
very peculiar (said in creepy voice)
At first I thought this was going to be a kind of lame experiment, because a heart is just a giant muscle.
Putting this in a vacuum chamber I wouldn't really expect much to happen at all
So now's the time that we can make our predictions
about what you think is going to happen
is anything going to happen at all? Or is this heart just going to sit there and do absolutely nothing?
I can stick my finger down inside there
Whatever this flappy thing on top is got cut apparently
and its got little tubes in there
Actually a lot of little tubes.
I guess that's the question is the tissue airtight?
or will the air just suck right out of it?
there's only one way to find out exactly what's going to happen and that's to plop this thing in
and start drawing a vacuum
I'm going to buff this thing up a little bit so that we get a nice clear view down inside
And I'm using the glass jar so that we can see inside from every different angle as well
Beautiful
It's looking good
(Blowing noises)
So we've got our jar of heart
(song) collecting your jar of hearts
What's going to happen?
There's only one way to find out (song ends)
gauges are set, valves are closed
here we go
Mechanical whirring
K we're all ready at 25 inches of mercury
that sucked up really fast
and its hard to tell, but I can't really notice any visible change
in the heart, I can't even see if it got bigger or not
looks completely the same to me
from every angle
26.5 inches of mercury that's as much as this vacuum chamber can pull
hmm